une navette rouge qui se déplacent sans
bruit mais surtout sans chauffeur voilà
peut-être à quoi ressemblera le véhicule
que nous emprunterons dans quelques
années pour faire nos courses ou aller
au travail
la communauté d'agglomération de
rambouillet présenter son projet tourne
à dos au public ce week end
un projet qui vise à développer les
technologies des véhicules autonomes et
portées par le constructeur automobile
renault
l'occasion aussi de se projeter dans
quelques années et d'imaginer des
navettes et voiture ou le chauffeur est
remplacé par des capteurs gps et caméras
en premier on a besoin d'eux des bois
qu'est ce qu'il ya en face donc il ya
les camara
des vidéos des caméras des vidéos il
faut que l'ordinateur qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est un piéton c'est un bel qst en vélo
donc il fait il fait la classification
ce nom mais aussi il faut que sa caméra
décès ces capteurs ils me disent à
quelle distance et 1b un autre véhicule
par rapport à mon véhicule dont il
mesure la distance les véhicules
autonomes sont désormais tester pour 3
ans sur le territoire de rambouillet et
en plus de l'intérêt technologique
évident d'un tel projet l'utilité est
aussi vitale pour les zones rurales et
cette mobilité fait partie jaillir des
deux enjeux de ce territoire qui émane
de la demande à la fois des citoyens des
élus sert la mobilité en ce sens je vais
d'un point à un autre et un autre sujet
qui n'est effectivement ne concerne pas
aujourd'hui qui est aussi la fibre
puisque ces territoires ont besoin
d'être connecté et la problématique
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont très peu
donc la mobilité est un point important
les premiers véhicules sans chauffeurs
devraient rouler dans des conditions
réelles en 2020 dans le sud yvelines
une fois les technologies au point et le
risque d'accident presque nul